[Music]
leftist political analyst Peter Bard is
deeply Disturbed that National Security
adviser John Bolton has chosen Fred
flights as his chief of staff writing in
the Atlantic Bart noted that flights has
for the last 5 years served as senior
vice president at the center for
security policy an organization that
according to binart for more than a
decade has been arguing that American
Muslims who observe Sharia or Islamic
law don't deserve the protections of the
First Amendment now this sounds terrible
if one doesn't know anything about
Sharia and Peter binart obviously
doesn't in a 2016 piece condescendingly
entitled how not to speak about Islam
binart scolds Rabbi Ari Burman president
of Yeshiva University for some of his
statements about Islam and concludes
University President should not lecture
on subjects they know little about bart
should take his own advice his claim
about Fred flights and the center for
security policy are classic examples of
the straw man fallacy Bart scenario is
that the CSP and flights overflowing
with bigotry we're calling for
law-abiding citizens who happen to
follow a particular religious law to be
stripped of first amendment protection
in a 2017 article hitting the CSP and
its president Frank Gaffney Bart makes
this plain by likening opposition to
Sharia to anti-jewish and anti-catholic
Prejudice in American history he he says
Gaffney and his allies view Sharia not
as a religious code but as a
totalitarian ideology cloaked in
religious guard Muslims who adhere to it
therefore should be treated not like
Jews who adhere to halaka the body of
Jewish law or Catholics who adhere to
canon law but like Americans who
espoused communism fascism national
socialism or Japanese imperialism during
times of War they should be treated in
other words like people seeking to
overthrow the United States
government that's what BART says and he
also claims that gaffney's theory
resembles conspiracy theories about
vulnerable minority groups in the past
yet in several articles that he has
written attacking the CSP Gaffney
flights and other opponents of sharia
Bart never actually gets around to
explaining in any detail what Sharia
really is or to refuting even one of the
csp's assertions about it he just
presents them as leftist writers so
often do in so many contexts as if they
were self-evidently false where he to
decide to educate himself about the
actual contents of this law that he
defends so ardently a good place to
start would be a book called Reliance of
the traveler a manual of sharia that
Alazar the Cairo institution that is the
most prestigious and influential
Authority in Sy Islam certifies as
conforming to the practice and Faith of
the Orthodox Sunni Community Reliance is
also certified as a reliable guide to
what Sharia is by Taha jabir alwani
president of both the International
Institute of Islamic thought and the FI
Council of North America and N A Salman
the Muti of the Jordanian Armed Forces
does this venerable Sharia Emanuel bear
out the csp's contention that Sharia is
a totalitarian ideology well look like a
totalitarian ideology it forbids
criticism of itself mandating death for
someone who mentions something
impermissible about Allah the prophet or
Islam also like a totalitarian ideology
it calls for the murder of those who
dare to leave the fold when a person who
has reached puberty and is sane
voluntarily apostatized from Islam he
deserves to be killed with Sharia
denying the freedom of speech and the
freedom of conscience a fully Sharia
adherent Muslim may find himself in
violation of numerous American laws and
there's more Sharia denies the equality
of Rights of women and even restricts
their freedom of movement once again
quote from Reliance of the traveler the
husband May forbid his wife to leave the
home because of the Hadith related by
Baki that the prophet said it is not
permissible for a woman who believes in
Allah in the last day to allow someone
into her husband's house if he is
opposed or to go out if he is averse if
a woman disobeys her husband in the
words of this same Sharia Emanuel her
husband may hit her would binart
consider prosecution under domestic
violence laws of a Muslim husband in the
US who beat his wife to be bigoted or
islamophobic he derides Fred flights for
being one of 16 authors of a 2015 CSP
report that recommended that the US
government revoke the citizenship of
naturalized Americans who in seeking to
insinuate Sharia compliant Norms into
Civil Society have violated their oath
of naturalization and allegiance to
defend the Constitution of the United
States but does Bard really favor the
acceptance in the US of such elements of
sharia as blasphemy restrictions on
speech the death penalty for apostates
from Islam and the beating of
disobedient women if not Bart should be
so kind as to clarify what action should
be taken to prevent the introduction of
these and other aspects of sharia into
the US and clarify when opposition to
Sharia is legitimate and when it Shades
over into being
islamophobic but it is unlikely that
he'll ever do that probably he would
consider the request itself to be
islamophobic also and will continue to
Tar Fred flights and other opponents of
the aspects of sharia that contravene
American law as bigoted Fred flights and
the American people deserve better I'm
Robert Spencer a shman fellow for the
David harwitz Freedom Center and
director of jihad watch this video has
been brought to you by the center for
security policy
[Music]